person is from your town and he has
burned a lot of [ __ ] bridges
yeah right uh not too long ago we
actually saw each other at a party after
he [ __ ] up
and i hadn't talked to him in years um
not because i'm angry at him it's like i
just don't want to be around this person
anymore but he
can't he goes i don't know he goes hey
bro like it's been a long time i really
missed you and the first thing that came
out my mouth was like that's funny i
haven't thought about you once
cold yeah and it's like hey i just
wanted to apologize like you know blah
blah blah like you know i just hope we
could be friends again i was like well
we're not gonna be
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode
of the genius brain podcast hello ed
park back here
again because we shoot two in a day
while we drink up and have some
[ __ ] fun
yeah this is the only time i drink now
same here yeah
i actually so um when we first met
was when i actually became a major
alcoholic
i wouldn't have known because i was a
major
you can't heal somebody who's going
through the same [ __ ] as you we drink
we drink so much we drink a lot so we
first
met and first thing we did was film kim
jong-il
uh becomes a rock star and then
we we went straight to tigs yeah
i remember i smashed there yeah i don't
i actually
every time i went to tiggs i was so
smashed i don't remember what
tiggs looks like like it was just a blur
i just remembered me just trying to mack
on these random girls like all the time
just trying to talk these girls i think
one of them was your friend too oh of
course
yeah yeah i think
seattle smalling bro yeah i was like
probably one of your friends and yeah i
don't even think i even found her that
attractive i was like
she seems fun you know oh wait no
okay no i'm not gonna say i know exactly
what you're talking about
[Laughter]
i remember like a glimpse of that but i
remember the next morning i was like
why you were just drunk and horny as
[ __ ]
hey man to our 20s
it was like when we can
we always felt that the hangover was
worth it i know
and you know it's it's weird when you
get older people like
you know our friends go like i get way
longer hangovers like your hangover is
the exact same you just care more now
you know what i mean like your hangover
is the exact same [ __ ] it doesn't affect
you anymore it's just
before you would just soldier right
through it you didn't care you know like
now i have some [ __ ] to worry about so i
can't get smashed
but right now i'm like slightly buzzed
and so i know like hey
don't have another [ __ ] three or four
shots you'll be dead yeah so
i i choose a lot better for me it wasn't
even about the buzz
it was just let's get [ __ ] up
let's just get blacked out yeah drinking
in k-town is one of those things that
it goes hand in hand and i'm coming of
age
yeah it's like a coming-of-age thing
right like i never did the like the tomi
girl thing or anything like that i
didn't really need to but
like um just going out to cape town
eating a [ __ ] ton of food getting
smashed and coming back to the apartment
and drinking some more or if we didn't
do that we would go to the speakeasies
that uh that was open to like 6 a.m 7
a.m in the morning
and we would just stay there and drink
all the [ __ ] yeah all night and then
come back to the apartment and knock out
till like 1 p.m
dude it was like i i would do that in
korea where we'd be at the nora bang
until the sun came up
and then we'd go go to bed and then um
you know but i was living in seattle at
that time and then i moved to l.a when
we first met
and then we we lived in koreatown and i
was like holy [ __ ]
it's like korea because i'd be coming
out of the nordivan
and the sun was coming out and we'd go
to 7-eleven because it's still open
and have their shitty ass pizza and
their like chimichangas rolling on the
roller
this will let you know spaghetti it's
the funniest thing on earth dude
well like uh so uh david cho took
anthony bourdain to sizzler
and he explained it like the koreans in
k-town when
that's having an american dinner that
was that was
our idea of splurging yeah so when we
go have a fancy american dinner we go to
denny's
right and i have a spaghetti like for
for me it was this joint called
jj north in sacramento which was a
buffet yeah
that was the fancy difference oh man we
had old country buffet
up there and that's where we would just
go all out my mom still loves buffets
dude it's so funny like when the
pandemic happens she's like oh
what am i gonna have for dinner i'm like
why do you consistently eat at buffets
dude me and uh my friend richard we were
in arizona
for the christmas break and as we were
leaving
uh we were trying to find a meal uh for
the road trip back to la
and we found a chinese restaurant as a
chinese buffet
and we were saying like we parked in
there and we got out we went to the door
and we were just like man should we do
this
like we were like really waiting and i
was like we i [ __ ] love
lamp buffet chinese food i don't know
why
because he's like i want this and he's
like like this is so irresponsible
we just got back in the car and we
didn't eat it
i can't believe this day and age we
really have to fight this [ __ ]
i mean there's a spot out in uh
riverside it was a joint called ho ho
walk
and it was you know the patent expresses
before pan expresses were really popping
you know yeah
and they just did what panda express did
better just not with the same business
model
but dude i would eat there so [ __ ]
much to the point where the person would
see me and they would just give me extra
food
that's how fat i was dude that's
same me the uh this hawaiian barbecue
spot
uh in k-town next to california donut
uh-huh it just says hawaiian barbecue
but it's just like they have chinese
food on the lam all that stuff chow mein
i went there every day after work for
a solid two years every day and they
give
mega portions mega portions and then i
have two spam musubis with it i can't
believe i'd eat that
every night and finish it because on new
year's
uh eve because i'm like well let me
cheat
right let me just get off keto and have
that
really shitty thing i ate every day that
got me fat right so i went picked it up
i ate a quarter of it
and it's still in the fridge so funny i
ate a quarter of it and i passed out at
10 p.m
and i missed the whole new year's i was
at home by myself anyway
that's [ __ ] funny it made me so
lethargically
[ __ ] up or i got some weird msg high
you know so funny every time i went to
work at the men's warehouse where i used
to sell tuxedos
i would eat at l l
the guy so if you guys are in the elk
grove area there was there used to be a
borders there
there's an l owned by this guy named
ping
ping would see me eat there so much i
would order a regular
but he would give me a large because i
ate there
every time for lunch or he would give me
a free drink you got to understand how
big you are to the point where you just
eat the same [ __ ] every day
only because the portions are so so
you're special to them that you gotta
they got to give you back yeah give back
to you for giving so much
to them you know it's funny we were just
talking about earlier where um
uh and it only reminds me of this
because the holidays just passed but
how you know with a lot of like younger
younger influencers i don't know what it
is like thematically that i've seen
constantly is how
some of these kids who become
influencers are
say lightly [ __ ] losers
[Laughter]
sorry
like uh i laugh because maybe i agree
and what i mean by losers is how they
treat human beings and people
right yes not because of like their
hobbies or what they look like that's
shallow as [ __ ] i'm talking about how
they treat people in the way they
develop relationships
and what they see as success and being a
healthy person
i this is why it's so important for
people to have a strong foundation
in in this city specifically because
everybody comes to the city
to be recognized right which kind of
ruins the idea or
you know it gives people a false idea of
what people in la are like because the
people who grew up here are not like
that right because
um you notice like not a lot of people
from l.a are from
in la are from l.a yeah they're
transients transients
maybe uh two the biggest fish in their
pond and they gotta move to la
and so they got this i don't know fire
under their ass to
become somebody i don't know my biggest
get their
fame cause like my biggest issue with
that was like when i would meet some of
these people
and you know close to my age or you know
close to it or not
and one of my biggest tell signs is and
this is for a lot of other people when
you meet somebody
and you go oh it's like oh like who are
your friends that you kicking with they
go oh i don't really have friends get
the [ __ ] away from me
when i'm finding out once again using
this word thematically
if you have gone 20 30 years of your
life right
and you have hopped around different
groups because
they're the problem most likely it's you
yeah it's a very
weird thing that out of 30 years to 22
years 21 years of living you haven't
made a single friend
right and now that you come to this city
these people that you met for
a hot second because you guys gain clout
with each other you guys create content
and you say these are my best
friends i love these people i will do
anything for them [ __ ] you don't know
these people at all
and the problem with that too with these
because i always hear these complaints
about people saying everybody's fake
around me the reason why they're fake
around you is because you're fake
yeah you have developed relationships
with people who
are just like you the difference is that
you can't see it that you're just like
them
it's like when uh dave chappelle's joke
where when you start off with hey how
are you doing
and then then the next person know the
game's on fine how are you
yeah right and then you just have this
useless conversation yeah and that
happened so much when i first moved to
la
i mean i was born here but i'm not
acting like i'm born and bred like
i spent a lot of my life in washington
the biggest difference for you two you
still have your friends
from back in the day yeah you still have
your friends just because you changed
your geography didn't change your
relationship with the people
that helped build you up before you came
here and you developed your your career
or your name for yourself
this is normal good healthy [ __ ]
and so when i see people who don't do
that it always makes me feel
very weird like for example right we we
know this person this person
is from your town and he has burned a
lot of [ __ ] bridges
right uh not too long ago we actually
saw each other at a party after he
[ __ ] up
and i hadn't talked to him in years um
not because i'm angry at him
like i just don't want to be around this
person anymore but he him he goes i
don't know he goes hey bro like it's
been a long time i really missed you and
the first thing that came out my mom was
like that's funny i haven't thought
about you once
cold yeah and it's like hey i just
wanted to apologize like you know blah
blah blah like you know i just hope we
could be friends again i was like well
we're not going to be friends
but we're we're civil like i'm gonna say
what's up to you
you know i'm gonna say hi to you and
stuff i don't but
you and i are not we're not friends i
think um
it it got lost because
of the language he spoke because
um he was very endearing
right he said i love you a lot a lot
um and it sounded like he said it
sincerely
uh but it got
lost between like where like you know
we're
we're in the quote industry business we
were
all doing youtube in one form or another
you know i was behind the scenes and
[ __ ]
where um i made this
[ __ ] me and dan made this surprise
video for them
right for their like it was like an
anniversary
show or something right and it was a
surprise
gift to them right of because i was
doing videos from them from
the start from their very first show
like when they were just some wrinkling
kids band you know
and then uh over the years to where we
come you know so i recorded
everything they ever did so we put
together the surprise video and we send
it to them
and then they re they asked me for
changes they had edit requests
dude which kid i was like me and they
were like
[ __ ] that we didn't do
this is a gift
that's so funny it's like you give
somebody a gift right it's in this
blue gift wrap with the red bow and they
go you know what
can you give it back to me but i want it
green with a yellow bow
i will [ __ ] slap the [ __ ] out of you
and like i said like this is the
that's exactly the moment though where
we were like
this whatever they say doesn't seem to
ever matter
you know behind it's all empty words you
know and when you look at somebody like
that and you say
where's his friends none
right just all the every person that's
been around that person is only people
that he
gained something from yes right and when
he
when he felt that he had gained enough
he would move on to the next person and
the next person
the difference between me and them was
that i'm very vocal
you don't do that to me and i'm not
gonna say something yeah and i think he
found that i actually made him cry
i made him cry because he was supposed
to work on a project in mind and you
know
and at this time you know because he was
doing what we were doing at the same
time it was it was good like i was all
i ed knows like i'm always down i only
work with people if i like them
has nothing to do with where you could
bring me fame or anything else it's like
do i like being around you let's do
something you sell yourself man
i don't know why people think that you
they have a hand in your [ __ ]
it it even it bothers me like you have
zero charisma to what he's actually
doing for you
in front of your camera so i don't know
i'm always just like i just like working
with people that i enjoy right because
time is so short right and and at the
end of the day i've already achieved
more than i thought i could
so now it's about me just having fun
with my friends
you know obviously i have a monetary
goal i have these things but i still
have to enjoy the people around me
yeah and that has that's always been my
motive even working with
with this guy right he i had nothing to
gain from him he had everything to gain
but he was very good with his words and
i learned early on
even before him but i kind of caught it
on early with him was like oh
you're a likable person you're not a
good person
you're very good at getting people to
like you because you say the right
things but i don't know who you are and
i found that out when we worked on a
project together and he left me out to
dry
and he wouldn't pick up my calls until i
threatened him and i was like
hey i'm gonna text you one more time if
you're not in front of my door in about
half an hour i'm gonna go over your
place and beat your [ __ ] ass
because you owe me something yeah and
then he came back before we continue
this podcast
let me talk to you about one of our
wonderful sponsors
ship station my friends if you sell
stuff online you're definitely in the
right business
more people are shopping online than
ever no matter how much you sell
shipstation makes it super easy to
manage and ship all your orders from all
your sales channels
faster yes we're talking about faster
and more efficient and that's what i
like you get access to discounted
shipping rates so you could save some
money
son no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy on your own website shipstation
funnels all your orders into one
simple interface that you can manage
from anywhere even
on your cell phone it's no wonder
shipstation has
more five-star reviews than any other
shipping software
so you know you can trust them i've been
using shipstation for quite a while now
and it's just a really super easy way to
kind of manage all the different places
that i'm shipping these products on
and it just makes my life easier and
you'll love it too ship more in less
time just use my offer code geniusbrain
to get a 60 day free trial that's two
months free of no hassle stress free
shipping just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in geniusbrain that's
shipstation.com
enter offer code geniusbrain make ship
happen
i went off on him he apologized started
tearing up and he left
and i was like how [ __ ] can you take
advantage of me dude like we're supposed
to be friends and this doesn't
this is not even anything big yeah you
know
it's like when somebody feels secure
in their relationship they just all of a
sudden seem to stop caring
or something or it it's like but this
part of your relationship is completely
transactional
it's like you paid him yeah this exactly
this is a business move
nothing to do with your friends not like
if you're his friend then you follow
through you have some integrity kind of
thing
um yeah i i can understand like
that hurt and that pain that he's
probably going through
because i failed i mean you know but you
understand
like the um uh i
i went through what he went through but
i never lost my relationship with you
because friends don't have to say sorry
right chingu
yeah i don't think he understands that i
don't think he understood that well
the difference between us when we work
together was like you had an inability
to work with me because you were going
through personal things
and you let it be known i can understand
that
i can't hate you for that yeah you
didn't we worked together and it didn't
work out because you had a lot of stuff
that you had to work through yeah how
can i hate you for that especially when
you came to me and you confided in me
what kind of [ __ ] monster would i be
it's like hey david i'm going through a
lot of stuff i don't know what the [ __ ]
i want to do and if i
still work with you i can't complete
this [ __ ] and i'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was i'm just gonna ghost this dude i
owe him something yeah it's paid
uh i don't i feel like there's another
project that's better so i'm just gonna
let him wait right
how [ __ ] dare you yeah i i felt like
i mean there's a number of people like
that they're all over la and we can spot
them out
um and they put people
they they see people as expendable yeah
i hate that
yeah i i can't stand it where it's like
i'm only nice to this person because it
can
it can i can ride their coattails or i
can find my
climb his ladder or their ladder let's
say or
i mean not that i have one at all i
don't but uh
i'm on the other end of being expendable
a few times in la since i've been here
so yeah it closed off for me a lot of
the
i'm very aware of the people i'm reading
when i meet them
what they want from me yeah you know
when i'm hanging out with them
and and i get really cross
you know with people like when i read it
when all i know at the end of it is that
they just want me to make a video for
them
yeah like i think that was really i
think for me that was the
hard thing for me to see when people
would be around you
because they knew your skill level and
what you could do because we would work
together
but every time we worked it was because
it was funny yeah that's it it would be
like yo
i have this idea let's film it right now
and we'll do it overnight and then the
next day
like that that apple commercial i know
[ __ ] two million views overnight we
literally just thought we didn't think
funny
and then we moved on from it you know
style
yeah we got drunk at a korean barbecue
and they were like dude what if we parry
the [ __ ] b
dan and dad are just cracking the [ __ ]
up we used
dan's konglish and that's the lyrics
that's how he speaks korean
exactly and then we created piantes
style you know you know what i mean
and that was purely out of fun you know
it's like if
i don't have fun with you why the [ __ ]
do you think magic's gonna happen
yeah like how yeah sometimes we would do
things it may not do that well it didn't
matter because i got what i wanted out
of it and we had fun doing it exactly
yeah
it doesn't really matter and then you
have other people who i know will try to
work with you
and they're like oh david didn't have to
pay you it's like yeah because we're
having fun your shit's a chore
i [ __ ] live with the guy bro
i yeah you share everything together
yeah not only that i know you got
sponsored
and you won't even [ __ ] pay me for
some [ __ ]
you would have to deal with some of the
most cheapest youtubers dude it was so
funny
and i'm like it's not even funny i felt
irritated so i did that video for jv
and three other dudes and one of the
dudes hit me up
later because it was probably the best
[ __ ] video he's ever had on his
channel
and he hits me up like oh my god i love
your video it's doing great
i want to give you this opportunity to
make my next music video
and i want to give you 50 dollars for it
my god at this point i was making 50
an hour at the corporate job i was
working at that's hilarious i'm like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] and i was so upset i
actually went to abe and told him to
reply for me
i was like i can't i'm not gonna deal
with this [ __ ] like this is
yeah i i'm speechless almost to a point
like i don't understand why people
really maybe i'm ex this is that energy
where people kind of like
want to take advantage well this is what
i hate like these people
who are these creatives right they
undervalue
what a director a great film this this
is there's a value and i mean there's
people who just aren't that great right
now who just need the experience
those are the people you approach you
don't approach somebody who's already
established that
that has already gone through thick and
thin and hell
to to create the stuff that he's already
created that has his style that knows
what he's doing to say
i have an opportunity for you to suck my
dick
that's my opportunity for you get to
suck my dick now get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah and i would see this a lot
with creators right
and for me too like sometimes with these
kids like i just want to create for you
bob for free i was like that's cool but
you suck
so you know i rather you get better do
your own projects and i'll pay you
you know yeah even sometimes like to
other creators because they're [ __ ]
creators yeah i'd be like i'll teach you
how to do it
they didn't want to learn they just
wanted me to just [ __ ] do it
instead and quite possibly just for free
too and it's just like get
yeah you don't have to pay rent too here
you know you're in my apartment this
thing you're in with
yeah we're having this meeting like it's
this is just weird balance too like i
remember this one person
who got really upset at me because i
paid them to
for four photos right paid them and i
put up the photo and they're like hey
you need to tag me and i'm like
and i wrote back i was like i was like
oh i was like cool
give me my money back it was like
i didn't know contractually i had to tag
you i wasn't even thinking about because
i don't really tag that much in
i only started tagging with people
started getting butt hurt i didn't know
about this anyone who ever gets butt
hurt about
not getting tagged are
it's this level of i'm going to say i
guess the word is narcissism i don't
know
i met someone who was so butthurt that
um the koreatown instagram page
it's run by stevie's cousin um
didn't tag her article that she wrote
for hypebeast
it's like you know the fact that they're
sharing your article
like your article's already being read
it's on hypebeast right
it's like she was so upset that no one's
gonna know who on the k-town instagram
it's not on the korean like hey these
people are gonna get to know isn't that
the reason why you wrote this article
so people experience koreatown and now
the koreatown instagram is sharing
she was just so incensed like and could
not
fathom like that this instagram page
they didn't even it's not like they took
credit for your writing
and when they link to your article it
says
what the [ __ ] are these so i'm saying
that is this odd level of entitlement i
don't know what social media has done
or maybe people have always been like
this and social media just exacerbated
the situation
you know even further but like you know
you're telling the story about
um can we say
well if you want to go through the work
later to bleep her name out
well let's just say uh the girl from
vancouver bc canada
okay i met this girl a long time ago
uh in vancouver bc through this asian
american show and clara was doing a show
there and we carpooled she flew to
seattle because we're friends
and we drove to do vancouver together
and she did the show
that's where i first met her and um
cool and you know when you're at that
time this was like 2011
right youtube's getting hot for asian
americans as a medium
to express themselves you know we
finally had a space and so it was
getting really hot then
and um good for her she jumped on that
train and um
she got a good following and so she
would fly down to la
after i had moved down to la um
to we'd have dinner and then have me in
a video but i would never shoot her
videos
yeah i would never direct i would never
do her work
you know and it came to a point where
like i'm willing to give advice and
stuff but then um it always
felt like she was just taking a whole
lot from me
um and her subscriber count is growing
that's fine
it's like i'm i'm there to help and then
uh
she had asked for khalif's contact and i
got them and i invited to a party that
she wasn't originally invited to
to come meet khalif and then she got him
in one of her videos
that video was doing well whatever it
grew literally after that
unfriended me on all kind of social
media no contact ever
again and how [ __ ] odd yeah and now
she's it was like after she had
hit over a million subscribers and all
of a sudden i'm just like
expendable yeah expendable it's like i
don't get better over being unfollowed
because maybe my content
a whack right yeah maybe what i'm saying
on facebook was so
[ __ ] up that she had to unfriend me or
whatever but it was just literally like
uh after just literally just taking
taking taking and
there was really no relationship you
weren't really my friend then
at all it was just oh 100 that's what
i'm saying like
i gotta look at somebody's past like i
don't even know this person like very
well at all but it's like
who are your friends let's just ask that
like who are your friends who who do you
have around from wherever you're from
and what do they say about you
right are they yours your network yeah
or is your friends your network and
that's about it
you know this this idea that you could
just take from some people and
just dump them off like they're nothing
but they've helped build who you are is
very odd
yeah i don't understand like how
ungrateful that is and these are the
same people that have complained that
they can't make friends and that people
are terrible
and these are the type of people
whenever they introduce me to their
friends
is this is my video guy like what the
[ __ ]
my name is ed parker yeah yeah it's just
be like my video guy and there's just
these stream of people
these types that keep introducing me as
their video guy well that's what i'm
saying that's why i said earlier to say
very lightly
[ __ ] losers socially
inept terrible people yeah like usually
those things don't go hand in hand but
it seems to be
the case here right like how do you
introduce somebody by their title
because what you're trying to show is
like this is what this person is worth
to me is when you say that
you strip them away from their humanity
when you don't even tell them their
[ __ ] name how [ __ ] dare you
like if somebody came up like this this
is why i had an issue with back in the
day where
when youtube started years ago um a lot
of stand-up comics
hated youtubers they thought that what
we did wasn't great
these people didn't know that i'm
originally a stand-up comic that went to
youtube because stand-up comedy
wasn't it wasn't that it wasn't doing
well i was a i was a pretty average
stand-up comic
but it was like you have to make a jump
between a club
to a [ __ ] late night show or like
netflix oh
hbo special how yeah so i had to build
my own path youtube was that in between
exactly i took my old stand up that
didn't work that didn't hit very well i
chopped it up made it faster and it was
funnier
on this three minute video than it was
when i was doing stand-up
i still had to go on stage and bomb and
then they started like hating on you for
being an editor
yeah it's like [ __ ] hey editing is
a [ __ ] solid profession okay don't
you dare [ __ ] talk [ __ ] about editing
but there was there was a korean comic
who i actually thought was
really [ __ ] funny yeah and i actually
met him uh through dumbfounded
yeah it was that uh it was at berkeley
we were actually put on the same bill
together to do a show
and i did better than him
right not because i'm a youtuber i
wasn't really well known at the time
i just did stand-up and i don't think he
knew that
yeah you know maybe he didn't expect
that he [ __ ] killed two by the way he
was [ __ ] hilarious right yeah i was
dying laughing at his jokes and i
like the guy i was like man this guy's
so [ __ ] funny and then lo and behold
backstage and abe is there too and then
dumb's like hey yo this is my guy
right and he's a traditional stand-up
comic another korean guy
i was happy to be introduced to a great
asian comic i was like hey what's up rom
davey go sup and i put my hand and he
just walks away from
and what and i had a really bad temper
back in the day yeah because i was fresh
out of sacramento you know so i was like
yo what the [ __ ] and then i i literally
said i'm walking up to an ape grabs me
he's like hey you can't do that i'm like
the [ __ ] this guy just did
and the guy just kind of like got a
little weird you know because i wanted
to sock him in his [ __ ] face yeah
it's like yo i'm over here just trying
to introduce myself and later on i hear
through other people
he's like yeah he he just you know
doesn't think that what you do is real
comedy i was like
you just saw me do a stand-up set i
smashed yeah like
the same crowd nobody knows who the [ __ ]
i am here so
what's with the disrespect i could
understand because we were both fat
asian comics
we looked very much alike and i think he
did like uh i didn't know at the time
but he did a kim jong-il thing too
i did the kim jong-il thing right but i
didn't steal it kim jong-un is a real
person
you know that's not your thing yeah how
many people impersonated clinton
exactly i didn't know that was your my
bad i didn't know who the [ __ ] you were
to that night
you know and all he had to do was just
introduce himself or maybe talk to me
and it would have worked out
because for me when i i'm like not one
of those stand-up comments back in the
day that was sit there and
in the green room and wait for my step i
wanted to go and see what people did
because it would get me hyped because
people would make me laugh you know i
was i was more of a fan
than anything else and i think when when
that happened i was so pissed because
people like him
would look down at what i would to do
and so we did another stand-up thing
where uh he was also doing the set and i
didn't really care at this point this is
like a year
years went by and also uh my favorite
standard comics were they're the
fangbros
dude they did they do they killed it so
good that nobody was laughing
so i know was that the ice house was it
the ice house it was
house what a note oh i think i was that
though
there was there was the ice house one
too but there's another one that they
did and so
hello hello my friends before we
continue let's talk about one of our
dope sponsors better help is there
something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your
goals my friends let me tell you
something i've been there before
you and i we're sadness buddies there's
a lot of things that we have to address
that we choose to ignore
but guess what with better help you can
start communicating with somebody in
under 48 hours and it will help assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional
therapist therapy has a weird stigma to
it my friends and it doesn't have to
if you need that help you should go and
get it there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas
the service available for clients is
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule a weekly
video or phone session so you won't ever
have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional
therapy betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today in fact so
many people have been using better
health that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all
50 states you won't be left hanging
dry this podcast is sponsored by better
help and genius brain listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
genius that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash genius
so i'm doing that right and my set
wasn't that great because i signed up
for this thing
super [ __ ] late right yeah and um i
didn't prepare a set so i had to like
just kind of go through my head of like
okay i got to do a they're only giving
me five minutes i don't know how to
five minute sets are very [ __ ] hard
if you guys ever do stand up yeah
because you have to somehow be hella
funny
in a short time without doing long story
telling so i'm like
okay i got to knock this [ __ ] out the
part i did this one little bit it killed
felt really good um but prior to that i
was pissed off
because they knew at the time what it
meant to call somebody a youtuber to
somebody who was doing stand-up comedy
yeah
and i wanted to be recognized as a
stand-up comic at the time because
that's all i wanted yeah
and it said stand-up comic all these
other people and then my name
youtuber and that person who made that
fire did it despite me i know
because they know how i felt about that
yeah and they wrote youtuber on it and i
was like
i'm gonna kill this set and you're gonna
you're gonna [ __ ] respect me
and they did after after i did the set
yeah dude i i can't tell you how many
people like after you
hosted collab like and that other
show at the avalon theater oh yeah yeah
like people
like even on my facebook speeds are like
i'm reading
david's show should do more stand-up con
like does davidson ever consider doing
standard comedy
nobody knew that you were a stand-up
comedian yeah right
yeah and i just remember yeah like i'm
telling you like we
refer back to that motel pool room yeah
you killed that set you can do it
in this in a small little [ __ ] smoker
room
yeah well that's what i'm saying is like
i for me it was a pride thing right
because i
started doing stand-up when i was 16.
and i developed this you know
at the time like very subpar skill i'm
probably nowhere near as good as it was
before i haven't done it so long
but having to build all this stuff to go
through the [ __ ] that i had to go
through to even be considered a decent
stand-up comic like oh he could kind of
do this
and for somebody just to just try to
take that away from me because
i am not what they expect me to be
it really hurt me yeah i mean it's like
they probably think that you didn't
you know hit the ropes like they did
yeah i always think like you took the
easy route
i told the story on um on this podcast
before but
uh when i it was my first night ever
doing uh a stand-up at the ice house
yeah and there's this guy um he knew
that i was a youtuber and i got on the
card
because of my youtube cloud you know
like okay well this guy let's see what
he could do
and i did pretty decent right i didn't i
when i look back at the set now it's
pretty terrible yeah but people were
laughing i don't know why but i thought
it's very forgiving like that
this guy goes up zero laughs
terrible standard comedy do you know
what he said to me before that what
we're
we're kind of chilling in the back and
he goes like oh so you're the youtuber
right and i already know when somebody
says that to me what they're trying to
say
yeah and i'm like bro i've been doing a
standstill 16. i'm 24 at this point
yeah you know eight years already that's
the kind of [ __ ] like
i support like if you want to use
resentment as motivation that [ __ ] works
that's when it works yeah and so this
guy comes up and he goes hey like
he goes like i've been doing center for
three years now so if you guys if you
need any pointers
just let me know i'll teach you what's
up and that's what i'm talking about
about the
people who look at people as expendable
things or as in as a hierarchy this guy
like read you and thought you were
somehow beneath him
yeah or something and trust me like when
i'm in
comedy clubs i want to laugh so bad i
think sometimes like i even laugh at
[ __ ] that's not funny
just because i'm in a good mood to be in
a comedy club that's how much i used to
love stand up
you know and it's just like why are you
at church
stinking it up man yeah we're trying to
laugh exactly so like i'm cracking up at
the standard comic coming he got zero
laughs
you know and i didn't laugh at his
because he already pissed me off and i'm
like damn [ __ ] this guy right you want
to hear the saddest [ __ ] about that
i thought he saw me do my set i did
really well more decent anyways right
well better than him better than him
anyways who messages me on facebook and
it's like hey like whenever you go up
next time like hey we should do a
stand-up thing together
you want to do a do it
[Laughter]
he wanted to do shows together it's like
[ __ ]
you you literally just insulted me but
that's what it goes back to that theme
of like people only want to be around
you if they can get something out of it
yeah
and it's like you just had to treat me
like a decent human being you wouldn't
even give me that
i mean like i said um it could be the
way that people
see the quote-unquote game of i don't
know navigating life
in la in the entertainment business or
whatever
because i see that behavior all the time
around people
who are established but i also see it in
young people
yeah because like um when i go to collab
shows
like even some collab volunteers they're
just kids they start behaving that way
and it's just like i just wanna yeah
like yeah yeah
yeah you know like uh i'm i'm a nobody
really right and i'm not going to tell
like
i just work okay and
um i just showed up to collab because i
used to volunteer too
and i'm having a smoke outside and this
guy who's a volunteer
just starts i don't know
how he's bragging but he's bragging
about his accomplishments which don't
mean anything
but he's just you know a pa at this
thing and he's a and he's talking to me
like
he can help me get into that my foot in
the door oh my god
and the thing is i'm just like i'm just
some [ __ ] guy having a smoke
and to him yeah maybe i am a nobody and
that's why he's just acting like this to
me
because i'm just a nobody and he's just
gonna
you know i'm gonna he's never gonna meet
me again and he's just gonna
understand an impression always treat
people with the same level of respect
that you want to be treated with right
especially if they're just decent people
like if they're trash treated like trash
whatever right and it's it's like this
level of self-importance that people
want to feel so bad
you know that's why like these kids who
are like 12 years old they're giving
a life advice on tick tock
you were just you were sperm like two
hours ago how the [ __ ] do you want to
give
you know what i mean like and what you
mean
i i s why i laugh so hard at like the
way you describe these people as losers
is because they act so hard like winners
yeah and you notice actual winners don't
have to
they never do yeah say [ __ ] about what
they've won
you know i just talked about this too
like i did a tick tock little quick
little tick tock rant and it was just
literally about like 20 20 was the year
of people putting up [ __ ]
motivational quotes
yeah from the biggest losers i've ever
met in my life
you know like these motivational quotes
are like listen if you wasn't hustling
in 2020 during pandemic that means you
don't really want it
like bro you still work at walmart
as a greener you're 32. you started when
you were 18.
how dare you how [ __ ] dare you write
this motivation who the [ __ ] are you
talking to right now right
and i think a lot of people they project
this stuff because they know they don't
have it
yeah and they want to be important
before doing important things
that is problematic yes you know what i
mean and i
hate seeing it it's like i keep saying
there's a there's one guy i [ __ ] love
he's somebody who's actually very
talented
um but he always has to post stuff
[ __ ] on what other people do
right like y'all don't do what i do i'm
out here man huh
i'm a i'm a ceo i'm a ceo too guy
it's called davidson comedy it's a
camera in one person
on my [ __ ] email i i write ceo of
david
as a joke yeah you know but there's like
this level of
self-importance that people want to feel
before doing important things
because it's that idea of faking it till
you make it they want to say
because they're misinterpreting this
this very simple advice that people say
they go
you have to project what you want in
life so you know yeah yeah
you're misinterpreting speaking to the
universe yeah speaking into the universe
so
it'll exist that's [ __ ] you have to
do stuff
in order to succeed just because you say
things it doesn't mean it'll happen
you know some wonder woman 84 [ __ ]
you know what i mean and so like i
always thought this was like if if you
ain't hustling whip or if you're not
with me you're against me type of [ __ ]
yeah that's like this is the dumbest
[ __ ] advice i've ever heard in my
life because
you're expecting people to quote unquote
hustle but it goes in that mentality of
if you're not
helping me you're useless to me yeah
which is terrible this is why you don't
have friends
this is why you can't develop personal
relationships because everything is
transactional to you
yeah i have friends who aren't business
owners who don't have a hustling bone in
their body and all they do is work their
regular nine to five and they're happy
as [ __ ]
and they're still really good friends of
mine yeah they're not helping me build
my future
they don't say supportive things and in
fact because they're from sacramento
i'll be talking them they go
what's up homo
what's up
but those are the people that i know
they have no reason to hustle hard and
they're happy the way that they are yeah
and you look at people
as if they're expendable that they're
only there to help you achieve whatever
the [ __ ] you want and if they don't fall
in line you get to cut them out
you're a trash human being yeah i hate
those stupid stupid memes
because they're useless they're not
applicable yeah exactly like i
i had beef with this guy in seattle he's
a christian rapper
god this [ __ ] guy
really had a problem with paying me to
do videos for him
i don't know even though i only ever
make [ __ ] lecrae
yeah no i'm kidding it's not like
no it's not yeah it's not but uh yeah
this guy had a problem with buying me
lunch too
and um i i keep me meeting people like
him out there like
someone who has a real problem with
paying me fairly
um and he gets they get incensed that
they didn't get a better deal
rather than me getting paid fairly yeah
that's so funny
yeah i had to uh work with somebody like
that and they didn't understand why
i was like people like that do this
really
um problematic thing where um
they want free work and they get upset
that the free work isn't as good as they
wanted it to be
dude like yeah i mean it's so
really weird logic that these
[ __ ] have because
like i said the birthday gift not the
birthday gift the anniversary gift video
where they asked for
the changes right there was a
another instance where
like this [ __ ] was bragging
about how much money he had
saved up in cash he said what do you
what should we do
should i go to like vegas oh bro i
remember this this is the apartment
at the apartment dude this is the
funniest [ __ ] thing i was like
bro don't you owe me like 2 000
[Laughter]
i mean this person is it's like he's
like a very socially inept
we we've accepted this about him right
yeah but this is the funniest thing
you know when somebody says something so
stupid and [ __ ] up
that the nicest quietest person in the
room roasts this guy so
he's sitting there he's like dude i got
all this cash that i don't know how to
spend
uh i don't know what to do with it blah
blah blah and this dude
this is paul paul kim is the nicest guy
you'll meet
he looks at him and he goes you [ __ ]
take us to vegas so we can party bro
like are you just [ __ ] flaunting your
money in front of us right now
you know and then this will literally
felt bad he goes okay well
when we when we go somewhere like i'll
pay for your guys food and he goes no
take us to vegas
[Laughter]
seriously like you got a mill in cash he
goes if i had a mill in cash right now i
take all of us on a trip
well i thought we're boys
[Laughter]
you know like how dare you flock this
when people are still struggling we're
in an apartment living with like six
roommates literally
he's just like i don't know what to do
with all this money we're all huddled
here
like because like wow we're friends yes
that's one aspect of it but we save a
lot of money bro
what the [ __ ] you think we're drinking
at this apartment at do you think i had
to win a soldier contest
so we can have free booze it goes back
to the idea of people who are just
socially
our word yes you know
socially young it's very hard to deal
with and
at a certain point like you feel bad for
them because nobody either taught them
better
but at the same time it's like why do i
have to deal with this
you know what i why am i this guy that
has to teach this person how to behave
like a human being
i remember like when we were we were in
a circle talking about old church
stories like we always do
and this is that department and then he
got this guy's like
oh i used to go to church camp i
remember those old songs i could sing in
love forever and whatever i was like oh
wow
interesting about this guy didn't know
he's and then he goes
hey if i still go to church and pay
offering is that a tax break for me
[ __ ] he started asking how offerings
work
oh my god dude dude
i think this guy's an alien he's a
[ __ ] alien
like do you do if you ever meet this
person you'll understand what the [ __ ]
we're talking about
he's not a bad dude by the way he has no
evil bone in his body but we have to
deal with it he just doesn't know what's
going on
yeah okay so i don't play basketball
you your brother and khalif keep
convincing me to go play ball with you
guys
because well he's gone yeah he's you're
he's go cleef's gonna open up the gym
uh and serena let's all go let's play
i'm like guys i don't play you're like
encouraged me to go i got in the car and
i went the whole ride
i'm sweating because i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] suck at this [ __ ] right
yeah and by the way when we play
basketball i stopped playing basketball
competitively years ago even before i
met him
because it wasn't fun people get mad you
guys know when we play pickleball when
you're at a gym you always have an
[ __ ] that thinks he's the coach
you have another [ __ ] that thinks
he's going to the nba and people get mad
and they play
seriously i stopped liking that [ __ ] so
we get to the gym and i'm i'm playing
the best i can
i guess and this guy starts talking [ __ ]
like out loud i can hear him it was
jason chen
he's like man it sucks holy [ __ ] he
can't pl
why is he playing like he's literally
belittling this dude
who number one ed is fat as [ __ ] at this
point right very unathletic fat you know
i've played ball my whole life right and
this is before knee injuries and
everything this is my knees were [ __ ]
that my angles were [ __ ] up so i can't
play as i used to but
ed doesn't play and we know this he
knows this too
jason you [ __ ] knew this right jason
knew
that he can't play ball and he's
verbally just
destroying this dude when we're all just
trying to have fun
but out of nowhere all of a sudden i
hear
he doesn't play ball
he leave him alone he doesn't play
basketball he started cursing him
out like i was like
like thanks for coming for my
[ __ ] like i said i love jason chen
but i got so
[ __ ] mad at him because we are here
as friends
read the [ __ ] room you
[ __ ] pasty sweet little [ __ ] i love
you
but that was the one time jason pissed
me off because
we are all here as friends and we're
doing this just
and we had to convince him to come out
he knew this you know
and the guy's literally telling ed how
much he sucks how bad he is
and i just got fed up with it and i was
like oh are you trying to bully somebody
right now
you know i hate bullying yeah and for
one thing too it's just like
knowing look it's just like come on man
why are you doing this to me right now
it's like i already feel bad that i suck
yeah not only that is just
like what are you trying to do yeah make
him play better yeah
you know and so the funny thing about
that was too is like
the reason why this should be very
apparent that nobody's playing series
khalif was a pro international ball
player
and he's playing with us losers
right khalif is passing the ball only he
knows
we're not that good and khalif is
playing it down a little bit and you
just hear this five foot one little
geisha
screaming at this fat fat dude for not
knowing how to play ball when it's
already known
yeah like he's missing shots and we're
just having fun i don't even have
basketball shoes
no you know and so i remember i got
pissed i was just like yelling at him
like i'm not only that like
retaining the basketball still was
even before that you were living uh
before we moved in together i was just
visiting and you
like [ __ ] broke your ankle yeah smash
it the piece
master ankle and your ankle was the size
of a watermelon
i thought i could carry you up the
stairs i could i couldn't but
um hey you tried my legs
i tried um we [ __ ] carted you around
in the giant orange count at costco when
you had to go cosplay you're
[ __ ] handicapped yeah but you show up
to an
isa basketball tournament anyway yeah
and you go one on one with jason
this guy he made a video like
like schooling like balling you
up with a broken ankle can i tell you
this too by the way i'm like 260 pounds
i actually fractured my ankle in
multiple places and i tore all the
ligaments in my ankle
that's how bad it was because i went up
for a [ __ ] layup and i landed on
casey's foot and i shattered my
ankle yeah it was that bad i actually
have only about like 67
70 mobility in his ankle till this day
that's how bad that injury is
and this fool's like over here trying to
post me up in a video and i'm like are
you
exploiting my [ __ ] up vehicle this is
what we're the the theme of what we're
talking about if you're getting it so
far it's expendability
and exploiting like even if you're
[ __ ]
down yeah this is just funny stories
about him like i said once again i love
jason i want people to understand that
that jason is not a bad person
no he's not socially he's [ __ ] weird
sometimes yeah i just remember that too
because like
when i saw him like getting mad at ed
like it just
because i'm a big guy jason's smaller
than me and i wanted him to feel like
you know what you want to know what it
feels like to get bullied
hey old boy mirror that's what it was
like
you want to bully somebody i was like
you know i could beat your [ __ ] ass
right now
right but i'm not doing it so leave him
alone
you know i get a little protective you
know i thank you for that
thank you for that you know if somebody
treated jason that way i would have done
the same thing for jason
you know and that's what's the weird
part for me it's like you're shorter
than me
i mean you're obviously extruding this
complex
out loud and i'm like i just don't know
how to
process what's happening dude one of the
funny i'm not sure maybe i told the
story on
on the podcast before but uh joseph
vincent
also saw me really angry once and it was
uh
this is also jason this is the first
time they both saw me angry
because i'm a very jolly happy dude yeah
i gotta talk [ __ ] but i'm always 99
i'm really happy but we're playing ball
it was at
24 hours it was super late at night i
actually gave joseph vincent something
called jacked
uh and he was on this the pre-workout
yeah
and he was [ __ ] zooming right we're
playing ball
there's one white dude comes up and he
uh checks me super hard cause i was
getting this dude
on the court he [ __ ] shoulder checks
me in the middle of my chest and i go
flying i get up i see [ __ ] pure red
this is less playing basketball
i start cracking my fist into the
[ __ ] wall immediately
and i'm like [ __ ] pissed and the
whole everybody stares
i start walking towards him like about
to whoop this fool's ass he goes
bro i'm so sorry and i'm like it's all
good man
and i just gave him a hug right in the
middle i started hugging him
yeah good dude and then jason looks he
goes
what the [ __ ] was it people don't
understand that han yeah
it is the there is a split personality
it is
it is binary nature where it's extreme
hate
and a lot of love but it's both at the
same time
it's weird people can't understand that
contradiction about the han
it makes you seem like a crazy person
crazy person so i mean
so uh this is in 2017
january right i remember this date
because it's a really crazy story
uh i just left l.a and now i'm in
washington
right and i think i'm a failure because
i'm leaving a lay up my dreams of being
a director and all that [ __ ]
and i'm in this podunk town now right
yeah
and i'm trying to process and deal with
having to live here now i know going
this was instagram
and he just did a collage of this guy
that i love that came to his gas station
it's this dude that would never [ __ ]
pass him money to his head
ever and ed's hand is out like this
as if he's asking for a loaf of bread
it was my coping mechanism to have to
deal with that [ __ ] was to just
laugh this is the if you if you're gonna
hear our old boy
review it's about laughing in the midst
of all this pain
but um so i'm at i'm in this podong town
and it [ __ ] sucks and i'm dealing
processing like how do i live here
right and i'll go to safeway
because i want like their shitty chinese
food you know i don't know i keep
mentioning shitty chinese
warms the soul so i go over there
and i'm i'm probably looking for
something and
i hear this voice and it goes
if you want the chicken in general then
it's gonna be 549
right and in my head i'm like wow they
actually have a chinese
chef here cooking the food because it
was a really good like despite my
impression it was actually really good
yeah and i turned a look and it was just
this
white lady and she's telling customers
who are making order like
you want the combo see she's doing a
really good chinese accent right what
the [ __ ] and
but for me just um
you know how i grew up out there yeah
all white high school and the way they
mocked me in my life well traumatic yeah
like i got triggered really [ __ ] hard
and i'm gonna i'm gonna confront this
[ __ ]
like straight up and and she didn't see
me so when i walked up to her
and obviously she saw an asian face she
went pale like
yeah and i said do you talk like that
all the time or are you making a joke
you know yeah and she was like um
and i was like if you talk like that all
the time it's fine like i can't blame
you you know that's why she's like i'm
just highlighting
but she starts going off like this
is america and i can say whatever i want
like you can't like let all this [ __ ] oh
perfect and i'm like hey give me the
number five [ __ ] bag
like and now the customers around are
literally seeing this happen this asian
guy walk up like in the middle of this
lady doing this bit
and and they're it's just super awkward
for them
and she's like i know chinese people and
they're my friends and i love them and
i'm just
kind of a racist right there and i'm
just like cool you know but this isn't
like
super bowl sunday when you're at home
with your friends you're the [ __ ]
business
you're at safeway and you have a safeway
name tag on right now
right and she was like you can't
you can't stop my freedom of speech and
my first amendment rights
and all this and and then i was just
like
man i've just had enough there's no
chain in this girl yeah it's just like
whatever and i turned around and walked
away
and then she goes i don't hate anyone
i love everybody i can love you too
so i turned around and i walked up to
her
and i said can i give you a hug
and she just gave me this big fat hug
and she started
bawling in my arms i'm sorry
i'm so sorry i didn't mean to offend you
i didn't know this was offensive yeah
and then i was like
i just said i love you too and you're
not a racist
yeah it's okay you know she was like i'm
sorry i'm sorry this is the middle
safeway
in the [ __ ] deli and then everybody
just goes no
nobody was that's the thing nobody was
there everyone bounced because it was so
[ __ ] awkward when we were fighting
she went she went on the defense mode
immediately yeah instead of saying like
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] up
yeah yeah yeah and for me at that point
too like i saw every
instance where i could have [ __ ] did
anything to this [ __ ]
yeah you know but i don't know
what the [ __ ] and i'm just calling it
the han or whatever i
or christianity to be honest i don't
know i chose to love
yeah the two extreme binaries like i had
a choice
and i did the most opposite thing like i
would have done
because of the trauma i have these
[ __ ] that's so crazy because
like when i see that when you start
telling me the story i'm like
i pictured this woman just her nuts and
bolts just [ __ ] flying out of her
head oh she was malfunctioning
i gotta defend myself i could say
whatever i wanted
yeah her teeth were chattering and she
was arguing for first amendment rights
and she's like
just say sorry yeah all you have to do
is apologize you were wrong
like my you know what i'm so weird
to the point where i'm like as long as
you conduct yourself and you don't spew
this hate to other people
you want to do this in front of your
stupid ass friends go ahead
you know i'm so [ __ ] up like that i'm
like just don't
teach your kids this [ __ ] and don't do
it out in public
if you want to be in your little [ __ ]
trailer park ass area town whatever you
want to do that to your trailer park
friends
keep it there i mean that's what's so
crazy about being out there that's what
i was introduced this was the first
month i was there it's like i'm not in
la anymore if you guys don't want
safeway as vaughn's or whatever fred my
supermarket
look at that we have a safely in uh
sacramento yeah it's just like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like because literally
they don't see
people that look like me out there you
know and i had to deal with that [ __ ]
and i had to find a way to choose the
love or
the low road i had like a weird moment
too back in the day where i was
introduced to this friend and
i don't really like her because it was
like one of those people that you meet
through somebody else it's like a
hand-me-down friend right
you know but she was such an odd person
because
she could only she could only understand
like small little microaggressions or
active races and when it was towards her
own culture but when she would do it to
somebody else
it was all good so she couldn't laugh
both ways she would
be okay making fun of somebody else's
[ __ ] but if you talked about her culture
she would get pissed i'm like you can't
have it both ways if we're if we're
friends here and you want a [ __ ] on
asian people
if i make a mexican joke you should
laugh yeah so like i'm talking about the
first time i met her right
uh we went on a rafting trip and she
made
like a fob joke like fresh off a boat
joe yeah like it's like oh this is
probably how you came to this country
hello
blah blah and all this other [ __ ] right
yeah i was like well it's better than
coming into an oil barrel
you came from the cartel you know and
that you know people laugh
and she goes too far and i'm like what
too far
what are you talking about [ __ ] you
just made an immigrant immigrant joke
like i made an immigrant joke
right like this is where it gets weird
now it's like
how can you dish that much and then not
take it
yeah i kept it in the same realm yeah
and then she go
one less like one of her family died
from the cartel my bad i had no idea
this is me i came in an oil drum
[Laughter]
that's me you know we had a moment like
that too where um
oh man this is a weird story we'll save
this one for later
it goes really long but yeah i always
found it really weird when people
couldn't
take insults very well right yeah i
understand you can get a little
irritated when sometimes jokes go a
little too far
but if you started it somebody's always
going to finish it yeah
you know so there's always like this
balance thing and i found that out
coming to hear that a lot of people
couldn't
take as well as they could dish out
right just because
i was always the butted joke in my in my
group because i was the asian kid
in a community full of black black and
mexican people so i had to say
crazy [ __ ] just so i could be on par
with people because asian jokes were so
[ __ ] easy you were always at the tip
of your toes yeah i had to be
all the time but because they were so
free with their asian jokes i was
allowed to say whatever i want
you know so it allowed this like thing
that's why i was able to laugh at a lot
when people make fun of me now that's
why i'm labeled to laugh at a lot
because i know that i could say
something else back and hopefully you'll
be able to laugh too
but if you can't and i make fun of you
then i just stopped making jokes at all
i'm like
you're clearly somebody who is who
cannot take a joke
that feels like it's only allowed when
you get to hurt somebody else
right but you can't take it yourself and
i hated that quality
yeah i see that in people when they
don't know when to laugh
do you ever feel that way oh yeah oh man
and
i don't know it's it always seems to be
a battle of morality
and reading the room
or at the same time like um
i i think people have a hard time joking
now because of the
climate we're in cancer culture does it
a lot yeah yeah
and so even i get caught up in someone
saying what i should and shouldn't say
at the same time i'm like i'm not even
[ __ ] famous yeah shut the [ __ ] up
i don't have i'm a freelancer and i have
nothing to lose and i don't
and if i work in corporate i might hurt
myself you know
it's just yeah it's not like you're
saying anything that's outlandish yeah
that's what we were talking about
earlier with this movie like it's the
truth
some people can't handle the truth or
some people can't accept the truth
or have a skewed idea of what it is and
i'm even okay with people saying stuff
that's
offensive as long as it's in the right
settings
you know if i'm at a comedy club and
they say some offensive [ __ ] i'm like
comedy club yeah they're trying
something yeah they're trying something
out
yeah it wasn't fun i don't have to laugh
at it but i also have a choice not to be
there i have a choice not to laugh
but it's at a comedy club so i'm like
whatever move on yeah you know i'm not
gonna make this whole post about it get
mad about it because it was
it's in the right setting because if you
were to
take that away from him to experiment
then you also lose
out on that you know that privilege as
well and if it's hyper offensive and it
doesn't work he's going to take it out
of his set
so i'll just leave it at that you know
versus the lady who's working at safeway
you know serving fried chicken the [ __ ]
are you doing [ __ ]
hello this right here number four hey
don't worry because there's no msd for
you
you know like yeah i'm like a part of me
is kind of like
man that's really accurate man is like
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah that was a thing i thought that
there was a chinese chef there that's
where
i was halfway like hanging on like that
was really good though you're really
good at it
but you know that's why i came with the
argument like hey you're a safeway you
shouldn't do it at work
yeah you know the funny thing is i blame
angela johnson for that [ __ ]
oh man angela johnson when she did the
vietnamese nail salon lady thing
it was so good it made me cry laughing
right
but that gave a green light for every
person and their mom to do a vietnamese
of
terrible vietnamese accent because
angela johnson does it really [ __ ]
well
that's why it's funny yeah russell
peters wrestle pizza does it
so good and it's there's cultural nuance
to it he understands like the little
inside jokes
that makes it so funny i'm even amazed
at dave chappelle's korean accent oh
yeah
it's like it's pretty good dude have you
heard daniel rawlings speak
korean yeah i've never died
yeah laughing so hard like stationed in
korea right
yo so did you watch christchurch the
cabin uh a little bit of it you have to
watch the one with daniel rawlings right
so there's this scene where it's bobby
lee daniel rollins and bert christopher
they're all laying down on the floor
and they're pretending to be each
other's father yeah right and then
[ __ ] bobby
does a typical black dude voice like a
black father voice right
yeah what are you doing danielle and
then daniel russell yo that's [ __ ] up
he's like
i was like what did he say he's like
he's like go eat
[ __ ] you [ __ ] korean yeah
oh my god crazy oh crying laughing
you know how i uh i say shangham [ __ ]
seki yeah
i got that from my friend sean that my
half-boyfriend
korea that's what he would tell korean
kids he's shocking the [ __ ]
when because he's you know he looks
white but when he was in korea
and he said korean kids would talk [ __ ]
about him in korean
he's like [ __ ]
so that's how what i learned from him
but dan
also pulled this off when we were in
k-town
um some norebang uh
at the zion market or whatever so it's
the top floor and now it's like
after 2 or 4 a.m whichever and we're all
getting in the
elevator right and the elevator's
getting packed and dan's coming in and
he's he's a little tipsy
and then um the elevator doors close
but then it hits his butt and he goes
i'm sorry right and he's being like just
dan himself right
and then this korean girl in the
elevator goes
right and then dan looks at her
and he goes you shikroy
she has no idea
she was so mortified she put her hands
right right
and like dropped down to the floor of
course he's like
yeah right
there
[Laughter]
oh man that's so [ __ ] funny i would
die laughing at the end of that it's so
hilarious when
like people get caught like khalifa has
a great so
you know khalif's dad so cleave is half
vietnamese
half half black right his dad is the
black side his mom's vietnamese side
so his dad actually uh learned how to
speak vietnamese fluently yeah
in order to communicate to his mom i
heard that on a very uh og episode
yeah and then same [ __ ] like they were
at the um
at the liquor store or whatever and he's
like teaching the one of the vietnamese
was teaching
uh khalif how to say bad words and [ __ ]
i was like hey don't teach my kid that
stuff and he just keeps doing it and
then he starts going off at him in
vietnamese
and the dude's like yo did they become
best friends
that's just crazy man that's so funny
when people get caught with that [ __ ]
yeah and they just start going off
because you know our my buddy pat he's
like
he looks full white but he's mexican as
[ __ ] wouldn't [ __ ] know and so he
he always hears [ __ ] yeah but he could
always go off whenever he wants because
they don't know he's mexican yeah that's
so funny i mean
on the flip side too like i've had
customers
like try to make me make fun of my mom
and do an asian accent for them that's
how i'm just like
[ __ ] you and like but then
um there are times when
um i'm sorry i totally lost my train of
thought
well let's wrap up this episode guys so
we shot two episodes today but
i hope you guys enjoyed that today we
talked a lot about
uh [ __ ] everything man literally
everything we were like what should we
talk about and i don't think we
didn't cover any of that [ __ ] we talked
about we talked about jason chen
being an [ __ ] a little cute little
[ __ ] pale [ __ ] of him
he's a good guy don't leave him alone
yeah this is just funny friend stories
that you guys get to hear this is all
stuff that you guys probably ever heard
before or you never heard but either way
it's all the inside stories that you
never get to hear about but yeah we
talked about that we talked about people
who don't have friends people who are
socially awkward
and you'll run into a lot of these
[ __ ] at a smaller town small
town people keep other people in check
when you're in a big city there's too
many people to give a [ __ ] about
everybody
so you'll see a lot of this behavior and
i know like people who are listening to
this who aren't from like these huge
metropolitan cities are like
how the [ __ ] do these people exist it's
because in a small town everybody knows
everybody
yeah you [ __ ] up everybody's gonna hear
about it it keeps you in check
yeah so uh you can find ed at ed park
v-p uh you can see the genius break c
you could listen to the genius brain
podcast every thursday sundays we're on
every audio platform out there if you're
not watching the video
watch it on your walk yo are we drunk
a little bit watch it on your walk and
enjoy
life i'll see you all next time
please
double penetration